social media is just one huge status
game dominance virtue and success that's
what social media is there's people
doing dominance you know being
aggressive to each other you know
bullying each other doxing and
cancelling and all that stuff there's
virtue people signaling oh i think this
is the talk about politics is all about
virtue stuff and there's also success
games look at my amazing gym body look
at my healthy breakfast look at my tan
knees in the maldives you know you know
one of the things i also write about in
selfies this is this idea we have that
you know these are kind of inventions of
silicon valley and they've kind of
created these things which have like
distorted the world and made us but i
think i don't think that's how it works
the selfie camera was invented as a
business tool for doing you know
conferences it was us the people that
decided to do selfies so what you've got
these technologies kind of working out
by trial and instinct what people want
and what people want are status games
and that's what twitter is that's what
instagram is that's what tick tock is
[Music]